Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Dan,
just checking in on you.
Just check it on your own little baby cry in the end.
My beautiful daughter is home now and uh,
she's downstairs sleeping,
so I'm gonna try to knock this out while a while.
She's still asleep before she wakes up in like 18 seconds,
which has been the thing hasn't been so bad.
All these parents,
all you were to go to home or a big goober day,
right?
I ran into parents tonight and I'm going,
no,
you know it's not that bad.
I'm a little sleepy,
but you know,
I'm hanging in there and then you know what they said?
Oh wait til she starts walking.
I just want to be like,
are you enjoying any aspect of this that I swear to God did gloom and like,
you know what parents are like,
it's like reading a Dan Shaughnessy sports call.
Just,
there's no light at the end of the tunnel.
Even if there is light,
but it's going to blind your eyes.
Good Lord.
I understand why kids run away from home just talking to all these fucking
parents,
man,
I just,
I swear to God I am.
I'm like,
I'm loving people that don't have kids right now.
They had a kid,
oh good for you.
Good for you.
That's great man.
Good you gotta you gotta be bright dead.
That's it.
These other fucking people,
I swear to God,
half these parents,
you know what?
They ought to stick them on the weather channel.
You know,
cause you know that that's how the weather channel,
that's how they make their money.
Like nobody pays attention when it's a beautiful day,
but oh my God,
if there's a storm coming,
you know,
they just start freaking out.
Getting everybody running out to the grocery store to bite nine weeks of eggs
because it's going to rain for an afternoon or maybe it's going to snow.
We're going to get 18 inches.
Holy Shit.
That's almost up to my knees.
What am I going to do?
You're going to be fine.
You're going to,
what was the last fucking time?
A whole town,
God so snowed in that everybody just died of starvation.
Has that ever happened in the United States.
I'm not saying a couple of fucking people haven't died.
There's always the person sitting in the car and the fucking snow comes up and
then the,
the,
the carbon monoxide goes in.
They'll always be some old lady sitting too close to the window and she'll die.
Right.
Cause it's snowed out.
Oh.
Because she was born,
you know,
three years after the civil war.
I mean,
you make the call on that one.
Jesus fucking Christ,
he's God damn parents said they just stay fucking scare in the shit out of you.
So I don't know what's going on in the world.
Um,
in a good way.
I'm having the best time ever been a dad.
I've always wanted to be a dad,
so I'm enjoying the hell out of it.
And I don't care if I'm fucking tired and I feel like I'm drunk,
you know,
I don't want to miss a second of this thing,
so,
uh,
I'm going to stop talking to the parents.
Goddamn Weirdos.
I just don't get them.
It's like,
what did you think was going to happen when you had a baby?
What?
What did you think was going to happen?
You know,
it was a baby.
You knew it wouldn't understand English.
Did you read up on it at all?
You,
everybody's,
you know what they sound like?
They sound like they sound like some people who like bought like a swamp land
and were promised that it was a paradise or something.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know,
but I'm,
I'm not going to be that guy.
If I meet somebody else who's having a kid,
even if I have a tough day,
I'm going to say,
hey,
good for you.
If that's great,
man,
it's going to be a great thing.
Good for you.
Instead of putting all this fucking gloom and doom and everybody's head anyways,
anybody watched the,
uh,
the Celtics supplies?
Couple of games,
man,
I got to love the fact that the fucking,
the Celtics and the wizards have this rivalry now.
You know what I mean?
Everybody's talking about the calves and the,
and the,
and the Golden State Warriors.
Hey,
we are dead tier two or tier three.
I love other wizards were all black.
It's going to be a funeral.
And she just fucking put your sneakers on,
pump up your little Reebok's,
whatever.
The fucking just go and go play basketball.
We're all dressed all in black or what does that mean you're going to try
tonight?
The other nights when he just wear your uniform or your regular street clothes,
you're not going to try.
I don't understand that.
I always loved that.
Way Back in the day when Kevin Mchale,
I remember we were playing that playoff series and we blew this team out the
first game and the other team was in the locker room saying that we better watch
out Celtics better watch out game.
Two cars were coming and Kevin Mchale goes,
well yeah,
you should be coming every night.
This is the NBA
completely diffused the whole fucking thing.
Oh,
you're going to try.
Well,
we're trying every game.
So you know,
just to keep it interesting.
Why don't you try.
Um,
anyways,
having said that,
I really liked the,
uh,
the wizards team man,
um,
young team.
They played great.
I just kept one,
you know,
basketball being a game of runs.
I just kept waiting for them to hit this streak where they weren't going to be
shooting well and they just fucking killed it all night.
My only complaint,
and I mentioned this tape,
I did Bill Simmons podcast hype.
My special that's coming out January 31st whoring myself out.
I was mentioning the only thing I did like about the wizards the other night was
when John Wall dunked on Kelly Olynyk and then he flexed afterwards.
I get it.
It was a nice dunk.
It was an explosive moves,
but at the end of the day,
you went around Kelly Olynyk.
Okay.
Who essentially is like a parking pylon that seven feet tall wears it a little
Bandana.
That fucking guy,
man,
I swear to God,
if he was six,
NBA loves a seven footer.
If you have a seven in front of you and for,
for your height,
forget it.
You're going to get drafted and you're going to hang around on some fucking
team.
I swear to God,
if that guy was six foot 11,
he'd be directing traffic.
Um,
anyway,
I know that's harsh.
I don't know shit about hoop,
you know.
Wow.
Whatever.
I just need,
he gets out,
you know,
he draws a couple of offensive files.
I'll give him that,
but he's always around the ball,
but it never ends up in his hands.
He tries to jump.
Okay.
Then like every 19 games they'll hit like five,
three pointers and every second here she's going to turn the corner.
Um,
anyways.
Yeah,
it was a great game.
Marcus smart,
having the meltdown,
you know,
wanting to be out there and then immediately apologized on Twitter's a lot of,
there's a lot of great,
you know,
Celtics away,
more fun to watch this year.
And I haven't been watching,
you know,
the Bruins as much as I usually do,
only because it's going to kill me to watch them fire Clo Julian.
I just don't want to see that.
I love that fucking guy.
Um,
but maybe May,
I dunno.
Maybe it's time.
I guess that's how it works.
You know what I mean?
The whole coaching thing,
you,
if you hang around long enough,
they're going to fire you.
Right.
Players go for the money and shit.
I don't know what it is,
but uh,
you know,
we beat the red wings.
That was a good one.
And we got the penguins coming up.
Maybe we'll see.
We'll see what happens.
But,
um,
we're still there.
We're still do the eighth seat.
Okay.
Oh,
what happened to the team,
man,
I've been doing that the whole game.
But anyways,
I watched a little bit of the whole year.
I've been whining about the fucking Bruins.
I'm going to stop.
Who knows?
Maybe a,
we bottomed out.
We're on a way to,
well,
the seventh seat,
who knows?
There was watching the,
uh,
the Celtics first,
the rockets tonight.
And uh,
you know,
I just got it on the NBA package.
It just records.
And what sucks is I wish it is anybody know how to set it.
So I always get the Boston feed because I love listening to Tommy Heinsohn.
You know,
he knows the game.
He's a hall of Famer and he's a total homer and he announces the game.
Like he's still sitting on the bench or are you still coaching the team?
It's fucking great.
So tonight I got the,
uh,
the,
um,
the Houston feed and uh,
you know,
so they're obviously pro Houston,
which I don't have a problem considering.
Tommy Heinsohn is so fucking pro Boston.
And what was great was tonight James Harden gets fouled,
spins around in the air and just fucking smacks.
Uh,
Yoanis Jerico right in the fucking mouth,
draws blood and everything.
And Tommy Heinsohn's flipping out,
I was able to see that Bill Simmons retweeted this thing.
So Tommy Heinsohn's flipping out and blah,
blah,
blah going you quite,
she could've called that from half court,
you know,
all this shit.
Cena was a total dirty play and the refs are reviewing it and the Houston guys
just going like,
oh,
that's just a,
it was unfortunate.
Uh,
Chi,
he was finished.
He was just trying to get his balance.
He was a,
he was following through.
It's an unfair,
you see,
he immediately apologize.
This is why I think the refs got it right,
that they called it a flagrant foul.
Aside from the fact that that guy was crying the whole game,
you know,
like young Sidney Crosby or Tom Brady at his,
when he's in a bad mood in anybody brushes against him,
he turns around and looks at the ref leggings.
That's my uniform.
Um,
I keep saying there's a pats fan,
you know,
um,
what's his face?
James Harden was acting like that the whole fucking game.
The whole fucking game.
He's just bitching at the refs
every fucking time.
Anybody comes near me once a call.
Right?
I mean,
maybe,
I don't know shit about who,
maybe he just was having a bad night.
Maybe the chicken usually banks it Boston when he comes to town,
fucking found true love.
It was on the rag.
I don't know what it was,
but that guy was definitely in a mood.
Okay.
It is a,
this is why I think it was a flagrant foul cause when he smacked him in the
fucking face,
he immediately apologized,
but not to Yonas he looked at the raft and went,
oh,
so like he was trying not to get the file.
Okay.
If you really,
if you fucking smack somebody in the face accidentally,
what,
who did he apologize to?
Some other guy that you didn't hit.
Don't you apologize.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Try that.
A Bar,
something like you don't get yourself one of those little girly drinks and spend
yourself around the floor.
It backhand somewhat across the face,
causing them to draw blood and then just pick some other guy standing.
Ah,
but it was an accident.
I figured that one out.
I don't know.
I love that he got the flavor and file and the Celtics ended at three game
losing streak.
But uh,
I'm really enjoying the,
uh,
the NBA.
I never,
I fucking,
I left it for so goddamn long,
but a hockey will always,
always be my first love.
I'm just kind of a,
I don't know.
I'm waiting.
I got a bad feeling.
Oh,
I got a bad feeling there that the hammer is about ready to fall there.
Um,
so anyways,
I've been whoring myself out like a lunatic.
It's why I'm taping the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
moneyball podcasts on a Wednesday night because I got to do some more stuff
tomorrow.
I'm doing the cow herd show tomorrow.
I did rich eyes and show today had a great time on that.
Did Jimmy Kimmel the other night.
They had a great time.
And uh,
you know what I've noticed cause both Kimmel and uh,
eyes and obviously a big sports fans and I've noticed debt like
okay
with Boston sports we've had so much success that they can't even trash the
teams anymore.
So now they just sort of go after you as a fan.
Like when I was on Kimberly was going like,
so like you have like a man crush or something on top for Kenneth came at me
with that angle and when I was on eyes and show he's going like,
why are Boston fans still so mad?
Like they've completely left the field of play and the other like,
hey,
you sitting in the fucking mezzanine level.
Whoa,
how come you got one ear socks pulled up?
And the other one is,
yeah,
I don't anymore.
They are,
you know,
it's just one of those,
it's just,
it is what it is.
That's how many fucking championships they've won.
They,
they,
you know,
they got nothing to say.
I'm not trashing to get one of those guys cause I like,
I like,
but I did notice that as sports fans,
that's,
that's kind of the way that they,
that they come at you.
But,
um,
I gotta give a big thanks to both of them for having me on this shows in,
uh,
and,
everybody at the Jimmy Kimmel show,
they put together this little gift package for my daughter,
a little Jimmy Kimmel,
uh,
the cutest thing ever for a toddler little coat and a bunch of children's books.
So I can't wait to read them to my daughter when,
uh,
I guess when she understands,
because evidently now she's just sort of,
somebody told me that they don't recognize anything.
All they see is lights.
Like it's an acid trip for,
I don't know how many weeks,
so she wouldn't stop crying.
And I'm walking around with their,
you know,
babies have this,
this thing where like if you walk around with them,
they stop crying,
but the second you sit down or God forbid lay down that kind of like,
oh wait a minute.
No,
no,
you're not doing that.
And then they cry.
Then you stand up.
I,
it's good,
let's keep it moving.
You know,
I feel like I'm an officer and a gentleman,
right?
And my baby's giving me the Louis Gossett Jr treatment,
you know,
making me keep my legs up but want to fly jets.
Right.
So,
um,
anyway,
so once I got that information that they're kind of a,
it's kind of an acid trip is a good way to stop your baby from crying I've found
is when you went walking around isn't working,
just start spinning going,
woo.
Right.
Just start doing that.
They just start looking around like it's the greatest acid trip ever.
It had just started looking around like,
wow man,
what the fuck is that?
And then they stop crying.
I just learned that 20 minutes ago.
I've only tried it once,
but it totally works.
You can also,
as you're doing that,
there's different ways you can spend and you can kind of lift them up and lower
him,
do like the tilt a world kind of thing.
Um,
for however long you can stand it before,
you know,
you end up yacking on your own kid,
if,
if you're one of those people that gets motion sickness.
But I found out that I found that that works.
So I'm trying to put something positive out there for all the negative shit that
I've heard about having a kid.
It's fucking hilarious.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
what else do I got?
Do I have anything else?
I got nothing man.
I feel like I'm drunk.
I've had such a little amount of sleep.
It's actually,
it's actually hilarious.
I've always found baby's crying funny though.
You know what I mean?
Cause they sound adorable so it's already funny.
And then all she want to be like,
like what are you crying about?
You don't have any bills,
there's no stress.
You know,
like what deadline do you have to meet?
what,
what's going on tomorrow?
That enough stress built up that you crying?
It's just strikes me as funny.
I mean,
I know they're trying to communicate before you give me your fucking kid pop
psychology fucking horse shit that I've just had coming out my ears.
Um,
or like if I'm on a plane and when kids cry,
it's never annoyed me.
Even if I get on the plane,
hung over the second kid starts crying.
It just makes me like,
I,
I just started laughing because I always think like,
you know,
that's exactly what I'm feeling right now.
Anytime you get on a plane,
there is that thing.
Once they close the door,
you're like,
oh,
it's gonna suck.
You know?
Even though it's amazing,
you can fly across the country in six hours is fucking incredible.
But it is not comfortable is far as what you're used to with comfort,
you know?
I Dunno.
It'd be great,
you know?
So what they should do,
if they ever come up with a time machine,
they should send people back in time.
Not to change history,
you know,
not to do something good like Tom Cruise going back and kill.
And Hitler,
whatever the fuck he was trying to do in that movie,
they should just send you back just so you could see how hard life was seeking.
Just stop bitching,
you know what I mean?
Or I guess you could go to like a third world country or something like that.
You know,
spend one day with like a fucking water carrier,
whatever the hell you call it,
their version of a canteen balancing on your head,
walking like 20 miles past fucking,
I don't know what God knows what kind of wildlife,
you know,
through a civil war and all this other shit.
You know,
trying to stay away for some baby formula that some corporation over here puts
out
fucking kid up.
Do that for a couple of days and he'd come back here.
I bet up all this shit that we bitched about probie probably wouldn't be as bad.
Right.
I guess you wouldn't need a time machine,
you know?
See that you like that.
I just worked that all out all by myself.
Here it is.
I thought we needed a time machine and all I needed to do was just travel.
And you know what,
I,
I think that,
I think there's,
there's some sort of something in that.
I have no idea.
Anyways,
I ran into that dude tonight who told me I'd never play fucking drums again once
they had a kid.
I was breaking his fucking ball so bad.
Are you going to be a data you'll never played drums again now really?
I went up to him.
I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
Why did you say that to me?
He goes,
you watch,
you won't.
I just find,
just said,
Dave Grohl has like two or three fucking kids.
He plays drums and guitar and sings in a band that travels around the fucking
world.
You idiot and he's cracking up laughing.
He goes,
yeah,
but then he's such a negative country goes,
but his drums aren't at home.
It's like,
yeah,
they are.
I saw the fucking documentary.
He's got a studio in his house.
He was recording with his band and in his kid came and said,
hey,
you want to go swim in?
And he goes,
yeah.
And he goes out,
he goes swimming and then he goes back and he writes another hit song.
I Dunno,
this fucking guy,
he's acting like it's the 18 hundreds and five are standing behind a team of
oxen and some kid came up to me,
I'll be a gag.
You know,
I don't have time to play with you.
I got to keep plowing the fucking field here.
I don't know.
I got to learn to block this shit out because I was doing so well and other
parents give me anxiety.
But I'm so proud of my kid.
Keep showing everybody pictures.
I don't show pictures,
but if something,
hey,
I congratulate you had a kid.
I just guy you brought it up.
Now I've got to show you.
I never thought I'd be that guy.
But you get,
you got to do it.
You got to do it.
But my wife gave me,
all right,
let's uh,
let's,
uh,
let's do this here.
Let's do a,
let's read a little bit of advertising.
Oh my mind.
My mother in law came over today and she said that she got upset cause she went
online and I was joking around on Kimmel and somehow they took something that I
said out of context and says,
Bill,
Bill Burr has a kid and doesn't enjoy being a parent.
Oh
Ah,
the Internet.
It's not even the Internet,
it's just fucking people.
Right.
And Shit.
That's the funniest.
I want to,
you know,
something,
if I could do this business over again,
I wouldn't be the guy I would,
that's what I would do.
I would want to get into entertainment journalism
because it has to be the funniest job ever.
If you're in a room with other people and just sitting there trying to think how
disgustingly out of context you can take something and just crying,
laughing,
thinking of the person that you're fucking over it,
like their,
their reaction to what you're doing.
Um,
I guess they do it so much that nobody really reacts to it,
but I always find it.
Ah,
I duNno.
It's just funny to me because it's such a [inaudible] thing to do and it's just
funny to me.
Cause you're not really hurting anybody.
You're just trying to get eyeballs onto the website.
Right?
I Dunno.
Am I still speaking English?
I swear to God,
I almost just fell asleep right there.
All right.
The black talks everybody
as opposed to the White Tux,
the Black Tux.
Oh,
by the way,
somebody said not to say cut too much in the,
uh,
in the,
the advertising read.
That's,
that's where I've come to,
you know,
on the entertainment ladder,
people who've just so accepted the fact that I'm a fucking moron,
that they just go a,
you know,
read it however you want to.
If you could just try to keep it under six concerts,
you know,
w we,
we,
I think,
I think we can enjoy it.
All right.
The Black Tux,
everybody looking great for a wedding or a special event has never been easier
with black tux.com with everybody knows it's not yours.
What,
who owns a tox?
Fiona talks like you,
you're,
you're in the Illuminati,
right?
Or you're like,
whatever the male version of Meryl Streep is,
where they just giving you awards all the fucking time and you just,
it just becomes like,
I got to get a Tux.
I'm a blowing 30 grand a fucking year.
All right,
let's start this read over against,
so they don't hear this part.
The Black Tux,
everybody looking great for a wedding or special event has never been easier
with black with the black tux.com as opposed to that black talks.
This is the black tux.com like the Ohio State University with high quality
rental suits and Tuxedos delivered to your doorstep.
The black gay.
What do,
what have you been doing since we graduated?
I delivered Tuxedos.
Really?
The Black Tux is giving.
You guys have new way to rent and get this,
get a load of this.
The black Tux offers free home.
Free home.
Try on.
There's a guy would deliver it.
Just standing there.
The doors just strip down to your fucking boxers or you just go,
I'm just going to come in here and close the door.
Is he standing outside?
They opened the door.
All right.
It fits.
What do you think?
I think you'll go right.
He's hanging in there waiting for his tip.
I'm going to get a Tuxedo just to see how this goes down and get this,
the black tux off,
free home rent or you can try it on and see the fit and feel the quality on your
Su months before your event.
The best part.
It's completely done online.
No trips to the Tux.
Well how the fuck am I going to try it on?
If it's online,
how do I do that?
Is there an app for that to have the robot me on the screen trying on a Tux.
Hey robot me really seems to like that one.
Imagine how well feel the Black tux.com lets you create your look or choose from
tons of stylistic styles,
stylist selected outfits starting at just $95.
These suits have a modern fit as Paul Paul's the old school ones.
We have balls just hung out this side.
These st got a nice and snug in a fucking 2017 type of way.
Um,
I love your balls are hanging in that suit.
I don't want to be an asshole here,
but I'm just saying,
you know,
that's really
okay.
That's a very modern way that you're nuts.
These suits have a modern fit and are made from fine Italian wool,
wool Tuxedo,
the highest quality on the rental market.
And if you've ever,
if you have any questions or issues,
their expert customers,
care team has your back every step of the way as a falling into the bedroom as
you're trying it on.
Just like some elaborate hit that they're putting out on people cause it is
Tuxedos.
Who the fuck's gonna rent one of those,
right?
Except somebody who's in power.
It [inaudible] be.
Just make sure you wear,
you'd bid fits you.
Can we come in for a second?
They take you out like a fucking Sam Jackson and Goodfellas.
You're sitting there and your skivvies after ordering your suit,
after ordering your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
That's a full two weeks to try it on and make sure everything fits.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a free replacement right away.
When your event's over,
just drop the rental back in the mail.
Shipping is free both ways.
How easy is that to get started now?
Visit the black to I did that like Christopher Walken to get started now.
Visit the Black tux.com/burr and experience a new way to rent the black tux.com/
[inaudible] all right.
That did not go well.
All right,
let's,
let's try and make it up on this one.
Distilled Dstl D.
Um,
if you're skipping your car payment for a new pair of jeans,
you're probably paying too much or you're driving a piece of shit one way or the
other.
Sure.
You want a bargain bin Denim that's going to fall apart.
Oh wait,
sure.
You don't want,
yeah,
you don't want one of those and your nuts and hanging out.
Right.
Unlike in those black Tux t CEOs.
Right?
But they're really good parents cost hundreds of dollars until now.
Distilled Peled,
spelled d e.
S.
T l d has revolutionized the fashion industry with they're timeless,
luxury grade graded denim.
So you get genes that would normally cost you a hundred starting at just 75
bucks.
It's $20 less than that fucking Tuxedo.
They eliminate it.
Excessive markups by refusing to work with middlemen.
Well,
what if we delivered it?
Get the fuck Outta here.
Uh,
they ship directly to you for free and guarantee the fiddle.
They'll send you a new pair until they're perfect is still genes are built to
last and will be a staple in your closet for years.
Hey,
come on in.
Now what?
I've got to show you this before you sit down and see my living room,
I got to show you these pair of jeans and got my closet.
Look at it.
And that beautiful.
That's a 2016 pair overalls.
I never where
there were a staple of my closet.
Uh,
the same goes for distills new line of jackets.
Whether you're after a classic denim or real stylish bomber jacket,
you can expect the same level of quality and convenience.
Go to distill.com/burner right now and get $10 off your first order.
That's distilled.com/burr for $10 off right now.
Five letters,
s,
t,
l d.com/.
Bar.
All right.
Sorry guys,
I'm fucking tired of this shit.
I don't want to read.
I didn't want to read when I got sleep.
Is Cso.
CSO is the place for comedy.
They won't tell you how amazing they are,
but I will see SOS.
Amazing.
It's comedy for comedy nerds by comedy nerds.
Cso Spelled S.
E.
S.
O.
It's the new ad free east as well.
I like ad free streaming server spring.
You hilarious original series.
I got a lot of balls.
Sand I don't like ads and I'm fucking read one streaming service bringing you
hilarious.
Original series,
handpicked classics.
Weeks of standup specials and more of,
what do you mean handpick?
Like the hanging on fucking tree?
Well,
you know,
hand clicked bingeable comedy anytime,
anywhere.
CSO,
every episode of SNL ever.
That's what it is.
What I like about this thing,
including new episodes the day after the air,
the tonight show starring Jimmy Fallon and late night with Seth Meyers,
uh,
the day after the air,
and they even have classics like 30 rock parks and recreation and saved by the
bell.
This is like the Lauren Michaels challenge channel,
right?
He's got all his shit on.
I bet he's got money in this thing.
Even British comedies like the original office with Ricky Gervais',
the entire Monty python catalog,
the it crowd and Steve Coogan as Alan Partridge.
That's a prequel to the partridge family.
Discover the next big names in comedy and watched the icons before they make it
big.
Like Louis C k when he had hair.
Chelsea Peretti,
Amy fucking shoe,
Bo Burnham,
and so many more critically acclaimed originals and exclusive content like
Harman quest created by comedian Dan Harmon,
and funny as hell,
a variety show featuring comedians such as Jim Jefferies and animal purse.
If you serious about your comedy,
you have to try and see.
So streaming anytime,
anywhere on virtually any device,
CSO is ad free and just three 99 per month.
Uh,
that's less than you paid for that latte or artists and cold brewed coffee
you're holding right now.
And right now my listeners can try CSO for free,
but two months when you use the Promo Code,
bird checkout,
uh,
shows you can't get anywhere else from critically acclaimed original series to
all 40 plus years of SNL.
You already said this shit.
See cells the only place down in the level of law,
go to [inaudible] dot com s e s o c,
so cecil.com right now for up to two months for free with the Promo Code burpee.
You are a checkout.
That's seeso.com promo code.
Ber.
All right.
Jesus Christ.
One more.
Alright.
Wince pronounced wink.
Finding a great new wine is tough.
That's why I've been telling you all about our sponsor club,
Gabby club.
Debbie,
Dick Cheney.
What should I think next?
How they make it's so easy.
Yeah.
You thought I was dumb.
Look at Trump.
Um,
how they make it so easy to get wine personalized to your palate and delivered
right to your door.
Um,
no more drinking and drive and they'll bring the booze right to you.
And here's a little update for your club,
Debbie and Debbie.
Yeah,
Bang,
by laying our aquifer,
want to get an aquifer and I'll drown so that we're scenes cousins.
A club w is now called Winc,
spelled w.
I.
N.
C,
a new name and an improved look.
But here's the important part.
It's still the same amazing wine company introducing you to wines you love,
your fucking drunks.
Wink works directly with wine makers and growers from all over the world to
create delicious wine delivered right to your door.
Winks.
A hundred percent satisfaction guarantee means if you don't like the bottle they
send you,
there were a pace,
she replace it with a bottle you love,
no questions asked.
Do this is a dream for alcoholics.
You just pound the wine.
Yeah,
and I like sucked down another one.
Hey,
I like that way.
They're
like down the third one.
It just fucking,
just keep ordering them.
It's gotta be a limit,
right?
Weeks,
a hundred percent satisfaction.
Guarantee means if you don't like it.
Okay.
I already said that you just don't send random bottles.
You don't just what?
You just don't get sent random bottles.
WINC is a personalized wine membership that recognize recommends wine
specifically based on the results of your palate profile quiz.
This is actually a great thing cause that's,
it's,
it's not like intimidating to buy wine.
It's just,
it's just like where the fuck do you start?
Wouldn't it be great if a bunch of people that love boozing it up and getting
fucked up on wine took the time to give you,
you know,
figure it all out for you.
That's what they do with this thing.
I'm off the copy now.
Okay.
The best part Winc is offering my listeners in anybody else.
They sold advertising to a $20 off right now when you go to try winc.com/bird
that's t,
That's where I was dropping.
That's why I kept saying the female anatomy.
Okay.
Try Winc,
C as in coach.com/burr.
They'll even cover the shipping.
Yeah,
I love that.
They didn't like that.
I was saying content mean that people will remember.
Think about that.
You'll get fine wine personalized to your palate,
delivered right to your door.
Try Winc and get $20 off plus complimentary shipping right now.
When you go to try Winc,
t,
R,
Y W I n,
C as in children.com/burr.
Try winc.com/ [inaudible] all right,
there you go.
There you go.
Right?
You got a Tuxedo.
You getting hammered,
you know,
drinking the wine you can put on fucking CSO,
Eh,
there was some other shit in there.
I can't even remember.
Um,
all right,
there's,
there's your half hour.
I'm just checking in on you.
Okay?
You guys ought to be checking in on me,
checking in on me.
Fucking nod enough.
Um,
anyway,
someone must,
a weekend to be a parent.
You know,
I gotta tell you,
it's pretty easy so far.
I don't know what all you guys have been whining about.
I don't know what you've been preaching about.
You know what you're so fucking concerned about.
You know,
maybe,
maybe you guys who are parents,
maybe you need to pick up an instrument stopping.
So goddamn obsessed with your fucking kids.
Okay.
I'm just kidding.
All right.
I'm just fucking around.
I just need to throw shit out there that people then can take out of context
because that helps me because then people search for me and then they'll
realize,
oh,
wait a minute.
This guy is a special coming out January 31st
I taped it.
The Ryman in Nashville,
Tennessee had a great time.
Uh,
by the way,
thank you everybody that bought all the tickets to the Patrice O'Neal benefit as
only a few left,
uh,
looks it's going to sell out yet again this year.
Very excited about that.
And um,
it's just going to be a great time in February.
All right.
Um,
makes a great Valentine's Day gift.
You know,
it makes a great me gift.
What if you're single and you don't have anyone?
Does that mean you shouldn't get a gift?
In order to find love,
you need to love yourself.
Well.
Why don't you love yourself and buy,
buy yourself a gift by a pair of tickets for yourself,
right
to the Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit.
Then you can go there and you can have a little bit of leg room.
You can look over.
You know,
as you laughed through your tears.
Realize that you're still single.
I haven't.
Happy Sad.
Just buy one.
Maybe you get on the aisle.
Who knows?
All right.
Have a great weekend.
You cuts.
I will check in.
Not Check in y'all.
I'll talk to you on Monday.
All right.
What's going on in spoiler?
There's no football,
right?
There's no football.
I tell you right now.
I got to tell you.
I'll tell you right up,
the soup ball's going to be a classic.
All right.
I feel like it's,
it's a,
it's 50 50 Pat's got a 50 50 chance and uh,
Atlanta.
Let's see.
Let's do the math.
They,
they have a 50 50 chance to,
that's where I'm at.
All right.
I would take,
if,
if Atlanta gets,
I don't like only getting three.
The bed I want is Atlanta getting points?
That's what I want.
I think them getting points is a great bet,
but not only three,
you know,
four is a little scary.
You start talking five.
That looks like a good bet to me.
And I can tell I can say that without a fucking doubt.
Cause I watched at least nine games this year.
You heard it here from the fucking freckles mouth.
Alright,
go fuck yourselves.
Have a nice weekend.
She
don't give a damn.
There has
to be plan
B.
I wonder,
wanted to
talk about,
oh,
so my wife
for whatever fucking reason,
absolutely loves that show that American greed and um,
she watches like three of those episodes every fucking night before we go to
bed.
And I,
and I and I always ended up falling asleep cause it's the same fucking story
over and over again.
You know,
it's the same thing.
The guy starts a fucking business.
He in the party,
he's faking it till you make it.
He gets a bunch of investors,
he hands out fake spreadsheets.
Then you've got these fucking innocent people just go and like,
you know,
all I,
I shy,
shy,
they recharge.
You know,
I was getting dirty,
appreciate it.
And I was like,
Whoa,
it's shower was like a good year or me.
All right.
And then they always go,
you know,
there's always get some really bad metaphor.
They invested in an ice cream chain,
but this wasn't the flavor they were looking for.
When do we return glass in the ice cream?
Oh Wow.
That fucking song for American greed,
I'll tell you,
and I was going to end up on fucking American grade,
is that cunt who shut that lion?
Everybody's talking about this dentist that went over and illegally poached this
lion that was friendly with people.
I love that shit.
Oh,
is it a friendly with people until what?
It bites somebody fucking head off.
Fucking unreal.
You know what I mean?
Everybody's fucking salient gas.
The pit bulls,
you shoot a fucking line every like,
oh,
he was nice.
He was a good line.
I'm not saying it was a bad line.
I'm not saying the guy shouldn't have done it.
I think everybody's missing the fucking story here.
Okay.
All right.
Speaking of American greed,
this guy paid 50 grand.
All right.
That's just for the fuck.
That's not even for this flight to go over there and kill this fucking lion.
All right.
Oh,
trying to stir anything up here.
But how to fuck in a dentist.
Afford to drop 50 grand to fly to Africa to shoot a fucking lion?
Yeah.
Illegally.
Okay.
Just take it.
Of all the,
how expensive the shoes he had to buy that he had to sneak around and they had
to be some sort of Ninja were fucking,
I'm going to shoot it.
Uh,
uh,
protected lion were that he had on,
right.
Guy Drop 50 grand on that and now he's gone underground.
They go over his house,
he's got a match,
right?
And all they're talking about as his fucking line.
And I'm,
I'm watching an episode of American greed.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
Ooh,
I got a fucking your phone off or I'm in fucking how many teeth you fill it.
This guy's pulling teeth.
He's,
I'm telling you right now,
I used to work in a dental office,
right?
And I,
there was some good dentists just like cops.
There's some good cops,
there's some bad cops.
And I'm not talking about interrogation,
talking about brandishing a weapon.
Uh,
no,
I'm talking about fucking people pulling teeth that didn't need to be pulled.
Fucking doing root filling fillings on teeth that did not need to be fucking
drilled into because they bought a car beyond their own fucking needs or
whatever.
Their,
their,
their financial responsibility.
All right.
I think this guy should be fucking taken back there just for the simple fact,
just for the simple fact that,
that he uh,
he went to another country.
It did that.
What do we got over here?
Does the MGM still have a lion?
What if he,
what if somebody from Zimbabwe came over here?
What about at the MGM Lion?
Right,
right.
As they were recording that you're watching an MGM film.
They fuck the police.
Turn the air conditioning back on.
Yeah.
The lovely knee.
Everybody,
she came in.
This is a studio man.
Dave Letterman had it cold.
I'm having a cold.
He lasted fucking 30 years on television.
I want to do 30 years of podcasting.
Huh?
Well,
what's good is the air conditioning.
If you're going to fucking turn it off.
Listen,
I'm talking about that dentist that went out,
went over to Zimbabwe.
You got to go grab a mic from the,
uh,
from the closet there.
I,
you know,
no one wants to listen to somebody.
Just hit pause here.
I fucking,
I never hit pause.
Um,
yeah.
Do you know that story in here?
This dentist from Minnesota,
he's a B.
You know,
like,
he's one of those big game hunters,
you know what I mean?
He's one of those fucking guys.
I'm going to shoot something that people think is scary and that could be the
guy I killed that shit.
You know,
like it went up and he fucking put it in a choke hold.
It's like you didn't,
you,
you went over and you shot it.
The fact that you can go,
you can walk up and kill an armed man,
a human being with a gun.
You could fucking kill.
You could,
you could tell it.
Even if he knew you were coming,
you have a gun.
He has a gun.
You could do that.
So now you're going up to a lion.
The thing doesn't have a gun.
So,
I mean,
how fucking difficult is that actually they shadow with a crossbow,
but there a reason why they shut with a crossbow is cause they were trying to
disguise it.
Doesn't he have,
he's gone big game hunting before,
right?
Like he's done an align.
Well,
here's the thing that I saw some weirdly alarm headline being like,
you know,
he's like a serial killer of animals and it's like they,
the way they were putting it was like,
you know,
this is what he does all the time.
I don't know.
He had him,
he's one of those guys,
he thought he doesn't seem like he kills to eat it.
A assists for sport.
Yeah.
He's one of those guys to be like,
Yay.
You ever hear of an alligator fucking shot one in their head as he put it up in
his study or something like that.
He's one of those guys.
So we weren't,
what about him?
He fled,
right?
Like he,
uh,
he will goes over,
he went over to Zimbabwe like a crossbow and he fucking went into some like
wildlife sanctuary.
Allegedly.
This lion was friendly with people.
I love that shifts all the lion see solo or whatever it was.
It was,
yeah,
it's friendly until it isn't for the one day you do something that reminds us of
something from his childhood and it fucking bite your head off,
but yet it's what it's supposed to tell.
What's a line?
Yeah.
It kill Shit.
Yeah,
of course.
So he went in and he fucking killed it to capitated.
It's skin.
The fucking thing.
Yeah.
He wants to head.
First of all,
how do you get the head back?
I don't know.
I don't want to know that.
You got to go gym bag.
Good.
Drain it out.
They probably do it.
They're like,
oh no.
You know what he did?
He probably taxidermy.
Well he probably like takes the fucking,
just the skin from the head.
You bring that back and then you just,
you have somebody like make a like a lion skull and then you put it over that
cause no one was going to connote the skull isn't in there.
Right.
This is the kind of shit,
this is like no idea.
Let me ask you this near because you're into American greed.
This guy's a dentist.
He paid 50 grand to do that.
Now he's gone underground.
They're going by his house.
He has a mansion.
This guy's a dentist.
He's a mansion is gone.
All these expensive fucking uh,
you know,
going around killing all these,
how does a dentist have all that fucking money?
Is he like a Hoity toity fancy dentist that like doesn't take any insurance at
all.
Like self pay.
And then I worked in a dental office.
Nobody was going on a safari.
Even if just look at them.
Forget about to,
I just want to safari.
How much money that is?
Forget about.
You're going to go over there and then sneak back later.
Kill a lion.
Butcher the fucking thing and sneak it back.
Yeah.
I don't know.
He sounds very sketchy though.
Oh Wow.
I will
drink.
So Liz,
Liz,
I've got it.
Go.
You don't know
cause he's not going to fuck with and what he wouldn't know cause we don't do
that.
You mean you don't do that?
We don't do that.
You guys like to do that whole race working with animals and I'm in listening to
what people watch these shows about like wilderness and survival and like naked
and afraid.
It's like,
I mean there,
there was one black dude that I saw in the commercial,
but like for the most part,
and you can always find one person that's going to be an exception to the rule,
but it's like,
I don't know why white people feel like they need,
it's a constant like fuck with or like be out in nature naked.
Like we've evolved past that path and why are you doing it?
I don't get it.
Yeah,
because we're bored.
Oh really?
Yeah.
We don't have a cause we're not being oppressed.
It's just you need to give you that sort of mirror.
When Russia 16 hours a day,
that's it.
That's what we jump around and flip around and skateboards and shit.
We're bored.
Oh Jesus.
That's so terrible.
I'm not saying it's terrible.
We're just board.
Generally speaking,
white people.
Remember when I showed you that for certain income we're board where there is a
white guy like standing on a cliff,
like I don't know,
like the Grand Canyon or someplace really fucking scary and it's like,
you know,
white people will do shit like this.
But then they'll like cross the street when walking on the same side with like a
black person.
I know they'll stand on the ledge of some fucking,
you know,
clever or like Mount Everest.
It's like what are you guys doing?
Like what are you trying to prove?
What all that wrestling gators in the by you like what the fuck is what I love
all that.
Why and Australian
fucking accent.
And then you brought up the by you in fucking new world.
Right?
Well like why I really though,
it's what the nature in the flocking with animals,
why do you do that?
I mean,
can't you do that with every culture and race?
Be like why do you do that?
I suppose,
but I feel like white people really like push the envelope in terms of these
extreme experiences in nature.
And like,
I don't,
I dunno because we were,
we don't have any gangs.
White people have gangs.
What are you talking about?
They're like a ferret.
Many.
There are many white gangs.
No,
but like,
okay.
Name Them Jesse James Gang,
plant gang.
Uh,
I'm white.
People have gangs come on.
You know,
like in certain areas like,
you know,
groups like,
well we don't have labs.
We have governments,
governments,
those are you?
I shit,
it's like main stream.
Okay.
I remember a long time ago I got this fucking hilarious talk with Patrice.
Can you,
can you push that thing so it's not rattling over there?
Oh my God.
This whole ac situation is,
it's what we live in an old house.
Okay.
The fucking heaters rattled a little bit that we run the AC through freezing in
here.
Um,
oh goodness.
You gotta fucking Afghan on.
I know.
And I'm still cold.
That's how I got this hilarious RB one day.
Like Patrice when he used to just get sick of white people,
would,
you know,
he just would stop coming down to the club for a little bit and then sometimes
he would call me up and vent about white people.
No,
he would vent at me representing,
okay,
what time I'm sitting at home just being white,
you know,
hanging out and having a fucking peanut butter and jelly sandwich,
phone fucking ranks.
I pick it up and like,
hello.
And he just goes,
Bill.
He goes,
what are white do?
And so you made me say a log.
What do you mean?
He goes,
what?
What?
What do you do?
I'm like,
I was like,
did you just get pulled over by a cop?
Like what,
what?
Where's this coming from?
Like what do you mean?
What do you mean?
What do we do?
Like what?
He's like,
what do you do?
Like what do you mean?
He's like,
black people.
We do this,
we do that.
What do you guys do?
You go as hilarious like you say.
Yeah.
But the thing about it is,
and as you answer him,
I fuckin answered them like I go,
what do you mean what do we do?
You just don't recognize our shit is mainstream.
It's,
it's like hiding in plain sight so you don't see it.
So you don't think that,
that you don't think that there's any sort of culture or anything?
Like what do we do?
Um,
the,
all the ECC,
look at skateboarding.
Okay.
They came from surfing,
you know,
and the fucking ways weren't there and Exynos skateboarding and totally evolved
in the,
to what that is,
what stock car,
Polynesian people were doing.
Stock car racing.
I'm not going to sit here and have you,
ted tried to tell me that white people didn't come up with anything.
I'm just fucking do that.
All the fucking Thailand.
Your most advanced ketchup.
Shut up.
I don't know.
Skateboarding.
Polynesians came up with skateboarding.
I know,
but escape.
I saw that documentary with Dogtown and see boys and a fucking empty swimming
pool at Santa Monica.
But I thought skateboarding came from surfing and this is only Polynesian
people.
I don't know.
I could be wrong.
He thought what didn't surfing come from Lang indigenous people.
Oh No,
I'm talking about skateboarding.
I know,
but skateboarding came from surfing.
It was sort of derived of that.
Yes sir.
Right.
So saying but then surfing come from,
so you're saying white people don't get credit for skateboard?
I didn't say that.
I was just asking who came up with a thing that inspired skateboarding.
I'm just wondering,
I'm just wondering what this is like.
Literally then this becomes the argument ended.
Pamela.
Patrice.
All right.
Stop cars.
Stock car racing.
Okay.
That came out of moonshining.
What does that stop basically during prohibition when alcohol was fucking
illegal,
right?
What you would do is if you will fucking bringing illegal booze.
Moonshine ma'am.
Oh cool.
You know,
cross state lines and all that type of shit.
You wanted a fast car,
but you didn't want it to look fast.
So what you did was it looked like a stock car.
I guess stock car you got from Detroit that just looks like a Chevy that looks
like a Ford.
But underneath the fucking hood you soup the fucking thing up and you were able
to outrun the cops and the cops didn't have fucking radios back then.
So these guys that did this shit,
all right would talk shit about my car is faster than your car.
No it isn't blah blah blah blah blah.
So they started racing and that started stock car racing.
That's a cultural fucking thing.
So then it's on fucking TV.
So I started listing all of that shit.
He was actually going late.
He said,
I think at one point he went,
he said,
good answer,
what he said.
And I just am like fuck you.
I'm not asking for your approval.
This whole fucking conversation is annoying.
Is that car race seem like something that's very important to people?
Like I said,
like a big deal.
No,
no.
You're looking at cause cause I know what you're going to do.
I think I came out wrong.
I'm not,
I'm not even gonna get into this
music.
And then everything in music is somehow going to go back to the fucking blues.
Like Beethoven heard the fucking blows and the fucking Irish music and all that.
He actually,
the nozzle be like,
well it all came from the Pyramids and black people built those.
How would you know that?
Because you went to [inaudible] dot com and you fucking read shit that said you
guys did it.
Like that is the dumbest shit.
Like that whole fucking credit thing is so fucking stupid.
Everybody for coming.
So that's African.
So that's black.
I know.
It isn't.
No,
they're not,
aren't there?
They're African.
Yeah.
So that's my point.
So,
so like when you see,
when you see an Egyptian guy,
right?
You think that guy looks like you.
Okay.
I don't know.
I feel like some of them are realized.
So I'm French,
German and Irish year French.
So yeah,
I have a little bit of French,
but I'm mostly German.
Irish.
Let me finish.
Oh,
so I'm European,
so mean Italians.
Yeah,
we're on the same fucking page.
So Ferrari.
Yeah,
that was us.
That was us.
That was pasty.
Freckle guys.
We did that shit.
Give me a fucking break.
No,
you guys invented like vodka good and stuff like that,
man.
No,
no.
Irish,
Russian,
sy.
Sorry,
I don't,
I don't know the history.
I didn't want to get into this fucking debate as more of a,
like a,
yeah,
German Irish whiskey.
Um,
what's the other ones?
Bourbon.
No.
Is that an American thing?
Most,
yeah.
They got just from Scotland.
Bourbons,
Kentucky whiskey was,
but Egypt is Africa now.
It's everything is,
was nausea's point.
Is that,
was that a true thing that he said?
Africa is a fucking continent.
Yeah.
It is not a race.
It's a continent where you go.
So like Irish people take credit for shit that happens in Romania because
they're all European.
I feel like those are reason why this is different,
but I don't know why I said I'm not going to answer that question.
Yeah.
But I feel like,
can I fucking have that written on a tee shirt?
Like
I feel like an Egyptian per se.
I am African or would they say I'm Egyptian?
They would probably say I am Egyptian.
Yeah.
I don't know enough about,
all I know is that all this shit is in Africa.
So have you met anybody over in Europe saying I'm European.
No,
they go,
I'm French.
That's true.
I'm swish.
This is a,
this is the,
actually this is like a toxic,
this always becomes a toxic conversation.
But credit man,
no,
I'm talking about you and me.
I'm just saying it cause I don't want to stir up everybody cause it's very
easily.
Yeah,
it can go off the rails and it becomes this big fucking race.
You're a fucking racist and all this type of shit.
Um,
resist the urge to read too much into this people.
anyways,
I'm just so soccer,
was it for white people is what you were saying?
No,
no,
no.
I'm not saying
wow.
You know what I hate about this conversation?
What I hate about this conversation,
I know it's easy.
I can't say I can't find anything.
If I say it like they can't come back and said it's true though.
If I say anything,
then all of a sudden it's,
it's this,
this and this and there's a whole bunch of shit that I'm leaving off
cause I'll then become,
I'll be called a fucking elitist.
Okay.
What did we do?
We fucking pretend to go the moon.
The space shuttle.
That's the shit where you just see it on TV.
Okay.
That's,
that's some shit that we did.
I mean that's,
that's kind of a cool,
no,
it's amazing.
I know the astronaut's weren't rapping.
They didn't have this space suits hanging off their asses.
I know that the kids didn't want but the kids coolest,
but the kids still wanted to do it.
Get the fuck out of here.
You got a mother fucker out there.
Probably a brown with the,
I'm just,
I'm just getting your go cause I see you wind to leap out of your skin right
now.
Uh,
I
hate when you do that.
My brother used to do that.
Do what you just say shit to get me going.
I'm,
I'm being honest with you and I'm saying what I'm feeling and don't just be
sitting and you think I can't say some shit to get you going.
I know you can.
You do all the time.
I'm sorry,
I shouldn't have mocked stock car racing or any of that stuff.
That wasn't nice.
Yeah.
The thing,
you know what the fuck are the,
is one of the greatest things about stock car racing.
Okay.
Is what's going on.
The level of intellect in the pit versus across the racetrack sitting in the
stance.
That's why I love going.
We're car races.
And is that why people think that are elitist or something?
No,
because you've got these guys like what the fuck they have to do because it's so
regulated now just to try to squeeze it and then the fucking hundreds of a
hundredth of a second to try and win this fucking race.
The,
the,
the level of science,
physics and all that shit that's involved that these guide,
the fucking eggheads shit that's going on in there and then right across the
track is just fucking okay.
Okay.
I don't know.
I went to the Indianapolis 502 years in a row,
I went to drag racing.
Do you know in between races they pull the whole fucking engine out and rebuild
the whole God damn thing.
Inbetween racist.
There's a whole team of guys.
Why?
I don't know why.
Because it matters that much.
Everything has to be brand new.
Okay.
I like that cool song you guys made up,
right?
Brand know everything.
Sorry.
Everything has to be fucking brand because if it isn't,
if it isn't a brand new fucking engine,
the amount of money they could you that split second it costs.
She was a different like six figures.
A lot of money.
That's what they're doing.
When they stop and all the guys run over and they're like,
no,
no.
And drag and drag race.
They're,
they're changing the engine.
I thought they were just like [inaudible] on the tires and like wiping off the
windshield.
No,
I'm not talking.
I'm sorry.
Oil and some maybe.
No,
no.
In that type of racing gentlemen,
Start Your engines on,
ain't one of those little air fresheners from the rear view mirror.
Right.
Um,
you know what I'm talking about a drag racing,
you know those long skinny cars with the big fucking tires.
Then they got the parachute comes out.
Uh Huh.
Hey engine sits behind the driver probably figured out to do that after years of
them trying to see around it.
Why did they have a parachute though?
Don't they have breaks?
They do,
but it's going 300 miles an hour.
Oh.
So you need all the help you can get and they don't have flaps to put it down
and you can't reverse the edge and like a plane.
I see.
And they're landing faster than a fucking seven 47 but it doesn't weigh as much.
But there's on there,
that's all the fucking physics.
Okay.
And it's also probably if they stop quicker,
they don't have to fucking make as big as a track.
And that saves,
the guy owns the track money,
all of this shit.
All his fucking nerdy egg head shit.
Hmm.
All right.
Okay.
So this is what white people do.
They get,
they get off,
they get on,
they get on a dirt bike and they figure out how to go off a ramp and flipping
the air two times over,
and they landed the foam and they figure out how to do that and then they try to
it.
Yeah,
they were booked board for fucking bored.
Why people need gangs again,
like if you notice like white people,
I thought we weren't going to get on all this and the 20s you,
when you had the gangs in New York,
was that the 18 hundreds of fucking bills
we would do you know what it was?
I know I can really track Matt,
Matt,
Matt.
Yeah.
I could really trash white people,
right?
Oh Man.
Was born to run these.
Do
what?
You got space.
So let's get
another job.
I got it.
No,
no,
no.